[Music] The
name of the village is called Arada Arada. It follows the Friday market and is
famous for cooking couscous. You can smell its
scent, spices, cloves and flowers from a few meters or a
kilometer away, so it means a main meal.
[Music] It
means that an agreement like this preserves our culture, not in
couscous, but in this, from one of the initiatives, I
mean,
for parliamentarians as a whole.  In general, they pass this
agreement and it is signed.
[Music]
Rather, it is a mirror that reflects the people’s civilization and skills that
have been passed on from generation to generation. The couscous dish
reflects social identity and the identity of society in a
very deep way, rooted in the roots of history. It has been passed on from generation to generation, generation after generation, from grandfathers to
mothers to
daughters, and its method is very special. It is difficult to overcome.  How to
prepare it
[music]